all right so this is the second Chris
Hemsworth movie that comes out this year
that was on the shelf for years the
first one was cabin in the woods that
was pretty awesome now we have red dawn
[Music]
red dawn is a remake film from the 80s
the original had Charlie Sheen and
Patrick Swayze this one has Chris
Hemsworth Josh Peck and Josh Hutcherson
in this film North Koreans invade
America because they want to take over
they want to create their own government
because apparently they don't like the
way the u.s. is handling things anymore
and they feel that they should be
invaded and so this group of kids
basically are able to escape to this
safe place they start collecting
ammunition they get a whole bunch of
people together and they start waging
this war against North Koreans they
become known as the Wolverines and they
try to make some sort of stand to be
able to fight some small war against
these people who are invading their
country this movie was a big mixed bag
for me at first and then it went in a
lot of very bad directions Chris
Hemsworth is a likable actor I like
Chris Hemsworth and I think he's good in
this movie I think he's probably the
strongest part of this movie definitely
acting wise Josh Peck let's talk about
Josh Peck for a second see I like Josh
Peck because in my later teen years I
watched the show Drake and Josh on
Nickelodeon it's probably one of the
last Nickelodeon shows I actually liked
and it was a funny show and he was good
in the Wackness
it's just that here something is not
entirely right see Josh Peck started out
as a fat kid then he got skinny now he
seems to be a male model who studied
under Zoolander his performance in this
movie just comes off so bad and I like
him okay I'm telling you I like him but
every time he's running around in this
movie with these guns and he's making
these faces and he's making these
speeches I can't stop but think
[Music]
I like him as an actor I think he's
funny I think he's a really likable guy
and the interviews I've seen him in I
think he's a really cool guy it's just
that I gotta be real with you guys I
gotta keep it real he's not good in this
movie he kind of harms the movie a lot
but part of me thinks that it might not
actually be his fault because the
direction of this movie is also very bad
it's very shaky cam style it's directed
by a guy who normally does stunt work
and if you look up his credits he has
done the camera stunt work for some of
the best films that contain stunt work
of the recent years but as a director of
actors I don't think he had his a-game
on certain scenes actors seem like
they're in different places like there
were another scenes and I don't think
it's entirely the actors fault I think
they're following the direction and a
very wooden and very basic script here
and it's just not coming off as real the
film isn't exciting at all it doesn't
have any real tension there are a few
fun action scenes but they're marred by
really poor direction and overuse of
shaky-cam the other thing about this
movie that kind of bugged me is the fact
that the villains the North Koreans it's
like they don't really have a reason
like there's one scene where in the
background of everything as these kids
assemble weapons and prepare this attack
you hear a North Korean giving a speech
on a microphone and he's telling about
how he doesn't like America and how he
thinks everything is messed up here and
that's it that's the only thing you ever
hear about why they're actually there
they just don't seem villainous at all
they're just there and oh they're from
North Korea so we're supposed to hate
them which I kind of find offensive I
guess I'm really hard to offend I just I
don't get offended that much but there
is an aspect of this movie that kind of
bugged me the kids basically turn into
terrorists in a sense they make car
bombs they collect guns all these
teenagers are killing soldiers and
everything because they're fighting
against you know these people who are
invading America and in that way you're
supposed to kind of think it's okay but
is this really what we need right now I
mean do you really need a whole bunch of
kids feeling all inspired and let's go
make car bombs and stuff like The Hunger
Games kids killing kids it treated it as
a disturbing and sad element this film
added a sort of Michael Bay ism to it
where it was supposed to be really fun
and entertaining all these kids killing
the soldiers and it felt a little bit
like Pearl Harbor the movie where
Michael Bay sort of made this big
Hollywood eyes version of a very
disturbing event and even though this is
fictionalized it just kind of
bothered me a little bit and it just
didn't feel right but there are some
good things about it I did like Chris
Hemsworth in the film it's not a
horrific Lee boring movie there are
people in this movie where you can tell
like yes these people are really trying
to do something here like Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is in the film for a while and
you can like you can feel like there's
something there and they have good
intentions but it just came off the
wrong way so I'm gonna give red dawn a
c-minus thanks a lot for watching guys
and as always if you like this and you
can click right here and get stuck my
knives
[Music]